tapez 1 tapez avec autour de la table
que tu as eue en démission si j'ai eu un
mec autour de la table juin mission
enfin je sais pas si maintenant on peut
qualifier dans l'état dans lequel il est
et qu'on peut qualifier de zazie jimi
art days qui donne soyez donc et si je
vais reçus en 19 cents à je voulais bien
avec un cadeau voilà je vais être un
cadeau parce qu'en fait il ya très très
longtemps
gilles m'a fait passer un petit message
pour savoir si je les avais je les ai
cherché partout et je vous avons envoyé
un petit mot pour voiliers a
malheureusement comme my way donné il ya
des trinômes invités je n'arrivais pas à
retrouver dans toutes les archives et
quand j'ai retrouvé finalement que j'ai
apporté ici et que je vous offre avec
plaisir donc c'était en 90 m'attendait
et gilles était venu s'exprimer
c'était quoi le thème à l'époque je
pense que c'était le nucléaire et des
chars radioactive s'exprimer beaucoup de
choses parisien non je me disais aussi
voilà déjà très en colère très en colère
ah oui le sujet me rendait fou ouais
mais n importe qu est ce qui vous rend
fou regarde vers des journalistes du
parisien qui est ici qui s'appelle
gilles verdez comment se fait-il qu'on
trouve du plutonium comme ça dans un
site ouvert en plein air avec un centre
de loisirs là à côté à 200 m et puis je
crois que je crois que le problème avec
le plutonium c'est que ça ne se voit pas
on laisse là parce que on sait pas si
c'est dangereux mais ça reste comme ça
bien longtemps vous savez c'est si
j'étais journaliste je forais un fromage
avec la peur
les raisons et lario la raison il avait
raison il avait réémergé de beau gosse
couvent et cet endroit là était
l'endroit où on mettait dans ciel mon
mardi les lapins un peu conscience d'un
chapeau et donne un coup avait un truc à
dire lui la planète est de là-bas je
sais sa femme me l'a dit